alors cette grève des enseignants est ce
un signal d'alarmé qui est temps peut-on
vraiment faire porter le chapeau
gouvernement pour la crise sanitaire ou
n'est ce finalement qu'une goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase elle aurait
comme le grand krach âgées qui la faute
on attend toujours vous avez le temps à
vos réactions sur le conte télégramme
verte et france et c'est l'heure de
notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau maxence briquet est membre de
reconquête le parti d'eric zemmour
bonsoir maxence briques et merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés vincent genvrin
orateurs régionale de valérie pécresse
merci à vous d'être avec nous et on sera
en direct tout au long de ce débat on
retrouvera tout à l'heure le témoignage
de deux enseignants qui viendront donc
nous dire comment ils ont ressenti cette
journée quels sont leurs attentes alors
on est un point de rupture ça c'est ce
qu'a déclaré le secrétaire général du
snuipp fsu premier syndicat du primaire
aujourd'hui est ce que vincent genvrin
vous vous partagez ce diagnostic
extrêmement pessimiste un point de
rupture je partage moi je vous savez je
suis mère dans une ville de 33 mille
habitants avec de nombreux groupes
scolaires quand on discute avec les
directeurs quand on discute avec les
enseignants qu'on discute aussi avec nos
personnels personnels communaux ou ce
serait pareil dans les collèges dans les
lycées on voit bien que là on a atteint
un point de rupture à 1.222 de détresse
on peut parler de détresse moi je le dis
aujourd'hui les enseignants étaient
considérés comme une variable
d'ajustement ils ont tout supporter les
villes avec mais on n'est pas face aux
élèves avec les personnels communaux
donc cette détresse elle n'a pas été
entendue et c'était normal
qu'aujourd'hui enseignants tout le monde
de l'éducation nationale y compris nos
personnels les parents d'élèves on voit
ce cri d'alarmé
faut comprendre moi j'ai une pensée pour
eux ce soir il mériterait d'être
applaudi à 20h au balcon parce que face
à des protocoles complètement
inouïe qui tombe à la dernière minute et
en plus la dernière fois pardon mais
chez vos confrères du parisien sur un
article payant à 17 heures la veille de
la rentrée c'est un scandale
effectivement lorsqu'on roule parce
qu'en plus ça c'est un scandale je n'ai
pas les mecs étaient bien la veille on
l'a tous c'est que c'est pas les
commenter en temps de parents le matin
même à l'école comme ça quand ça sort à
17 heures où vous êtes directeur d'école
vous le découvrez dans la presse ce que
vous faites l'effort de vous abonner
pour comprendre mais vous n'avez
toujours pas eu l'information officielle
de votre académie ça veut dire que quand
les parents d'élèves arrivent le
lendemain matin à la grille de l'école
et cuisine alors c'est comment nouveau
protocole bah vous êtes obligés en tant
que directeur veut dire j'en sais pas
plus que vous mais pour l'instant
n'ayant pas une autre nouvelle
notification j'applique l'ancien
protocole donc entre la déclaration du
ministre et la mise en place du nouveau
protocole il ya déjà quarante huit
heures qui se passe alors quand vous
changé trois fois de protocoles en une
seule semaine vous pouvez imaginer le
crack à ce que je sache génère et puis
pour les familles pardon mais le fameux
lundi moi j'en ai ma fille en école
maternelle et vous aviez deux classes
fermées parce que deux enseignants
étaient et était attendu qu viduka
contact va vous retrouver des parents
d'élèves qui a prévu de déposer leurs
enfants qui doivent trouver en
catastrophe une solution tout ça et
franchement j'avais en dépit du bon sens
ceci dit on était habitué puisque depuis
le début de cette crise sanitaire c'est
l'amateurisme complet mais dans un
gouvernement où le président dit à ses
ministres soyez fiers d'être des
amateurs on n'est pas surpris et
évidemment monsieur blanc caire une
immense responsabilité est objectivement
c'est pas pour rien que le premier
ministre a été obligé d'aller en
plateaux télé pour essayer de corriger
le tir je serais lui je m'inquiéterais
pour l'avenir de ses fonctions ce même
ministre qui dit on ne fait pas grève
contre le virus maxence briquet vous
vous auriez un diagnostic aussi sévère
que vincent jean brun sur l'action du
gouvernement c'est vrai qu'on imagine
que ce n'était pas une situation
extrêmement facile à gérer mais sont
très compliqués à gérer mais je vais pas
revenir sur ce qui a été dit shaw
d'accord avec l'immense majorité le
gouvernement fait preuve d'un
amateurisme complet je rajouterais mois
que j'ai vraiment une pensée pour les
familles pour les pour les enfants qui
vont en classe enfin moi j'ai un petit
frère qui est qui vient de rentrer au
collège qui va en pleurant au collège le
matin parce qu'en fait vous êtes obligés
de porter le masque en même temps vous
avez des enfants qui ont des difficultés
c'est par exemple son cas à lui et vous
êtes obligé
de faire en sorte que puissent apprendre
quand même il voit pas exactement
professeur vous avez des rapports
sociaux qui sont extrêmement compliquées
et aujourd'hui le vrai problème des
enfants ce n'est pas le cas vis de vous
allez enfants je prends un exemple comme
ça qui est statistiquement plus tôt
plutôt juste qu'à plus de 1000 enfants
plus de chances de mourir autant frappé
par la foudre en allant au collège que
d'attraper le comité dans mourir donc il
faut bien comprendre la menace que c'est
les enseignants peuvent légitimement
demander des équipements de protection
qu'ils n'ont pas il faut remettre les
conditions extrêmement compliqué vous
l'avez dit ils sont prévenus la veille
au soir pour le lendemain un article
payant sur le protocole sanitaire qui va
être appliqué mais aujourd'hui le vrai
sujet c'est une urgence
pédopsychiatrique par exemple vous avez
des enfants il ya des reportages qui ont
été faits qui était absolument glaçant
ou qui disent moi j'ai envie de mourir
et c'est un enfant de 12 ans qui dit ça
il vaut plus ses amis elle peut plus
sortir vous avez véritablement une
génération brisé que le gouvernement est
en train de briser et ça on peut pas
lier ne peux pas l'accepter le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanckaert ya une telle responsabilité
dans toute cette histoire on va tous y
est allé poser la question à l'un des
principaux concernés un enseignant un
qui nous a rejoint en direct par skype
fabrice fatin ni enseignant en
mathématiques et représentant syndical
cgt au lycée gutenberg de créteil il a
évidemment manifester aujourd'hui
fabrice frattini merci d'être avec nous
une mobilisation très suivi aujourd'hui
j'imagine d'accord avec ce que vous avez
entendu sur ce plateau et un jean michel
blanquer requis ce talent quand même
d'avoir maintenu les écoles ouvertes 1
66% d'ailleurs des français selon un
sondage c'est lui tout de même 7 cette
décision aujourd'hui vous vous lui dites
quoi aux ministres et qu'est ce que vous
en attendez parce qu'il va s'exprimer
non maintenant un quart d'heure
mais bon soir tout d'abord je ne suis
pas d'accord avec tout ce qui a été dit
par sur le plateau en tout cas oui
toute cette situation bien sûr que
j'accepte bancaire en portent l'entière
responsabilité
on peut ouvrir les écoles on devons
ouvrir les écoles nous et nos enfants
doivent être dans les écoles mais ceux
ci un prix c'est le prix de l'équipement
des écoles c'est un virus qui était
aéroportée la qualité de l'air n'a
jamais été au coeur des débats dans ce
ministère jean michel blanquer repas son
temps à rendre des centaines de millions
à bercy nous n'avons jamais pu investir
dans les écoles le seul investissement
c'est de tourner la poignée c'est un
investissement qui coûte zéro euro de
1,1 virus qui se transmet par l'air par
contre les enfants sont touchés par ce
virus très infime en notre rôle en tant
qu'adulte c'est de protéger tous nos
enfants même les plus fragiles comme si
c'était normal que les enfants fragiles
17 du co lead il ya eu cinq enfants qui
sont morts dans les huit derniers jours
duco vite donc parler de sécurisation
par les d'enlever les masques c'est une
erreur très grave nous voyons
l'investissement n'est pas n'est pas à
la hauteur et jean-michel bancaire avec
ces protocoles qui ne tient en rien de
la réalité de l'épidémie bien sûr on met
en danger et le protocole c'est pas que
des contraintes des contraintes
logistiques c'est des contraintes
humaines également les les enseignants
souffrent d'anxiété bien sûr bien sûr
nous avons une responsabilité moment
monstre à chaque fois que nous faisons
court allons-nous participé à faire
enfin faire en sorte que nos élèves se
contaminer le rapportent le virus chez
eux les enfants transmettre le virus
c'est une négation que olivier ferrand
et jean-michel bancaires ont fait depuis
le début depuis juin 2020 nous savons
que le virus est aéroportée ce n'est pas
du tout considérés dans les protocoles
sanitaires nous sommes au niveau 2
toujours au niveau 2 dans les protocoles
sanitaires y el vivero 3 et 4 est prévu
il y à des taux d'incidence qui sont
monstres ou ans il ya 2 ou 3 % au niveau
des taux d'incidence quand est ce qu'on
va réagir quand est ce qu'on va changer
quelque chose dans les protocoles si on
a envie de vous demander que fait-on
concrètement parce que vous nous le
dites c'est là effectivement vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec maxence briquet sur ce
plateau vous dis oui il est un danger
pour les enfants et également pour leurs
proches puissent qu'ils transmettent ce
virus
dans le même temps il ya ces masques qui
porte ce protocole très très
contraignant que fait-on concrètement
que demander de plus on réduit les
effectifs on a beau on embauche
massivement des enseignants ont
réquisitionné des locaux pour faire en
sorte qu'ils aient beaucoup moins
d'élèves dans chaque classe que l'on
puisse ouvrir avec un taux de co2 qui a
contrôlé par des capteurs co2 et des
purificateurs d'air r ce moment là le
stress sera bien moins - dia - chez les
enfants à ce moment là le taux
d'incidence et l'épidémie va se réduire
dans le pays à ce moment là des enfants
pour avoir des activités extérieures
sans masque mais tant qu'on est dans des
lieux clos et que mon compte en
considération le caractère aéroportée de
ce virus ne sortiront jamais il y aura
toujours des variants qui vont se créer
ce n'est pas la dernière vague on est
très loin d'une 1ère bac temps quand on
considère ce venir ce virus comme
commun voilà comme il est actuellement
peu par les protocoles sanitaires
vincent jean bras vous qui êtes maire
également vous avez été évidemment
confrontés dans votre commune à ces
problématiques
ce que nous proposent tabriz frattini
est ce que c'est malheureusement
réalisable et réaliste pousser les murs
réduire les classes quand on sait qu'on
a du mal justement même en temps normal
à réduire de choses il ya évidemment
dans ce qui est dit on peut pas faire
tout ça du jour au lendemain mais ça
fait cinq ans que jean michel blanquer
remise de l'éducation cinq ans
qu'emmanuel macron à la tête de la
france et on se dit qu'il aurait pu
avoir les choses nos mises en place
quand le gouvernement peine à aider les
communes à installer des capteurs de co2
ou déployer fille 14 heures la région
ile de france présidée par valérie
pécresse n'a pas hésité en quelques
semaines à lancer des dispositifs pour
aider les villes de financer ce
absolument l'objectif c'est de se dire
comment on est le plus réactif possible
vous voyez les régions arrivent à le
faire le gouvernement est incapable
fabrice fatin et au derrière je vois
c'est en train d'arriver les
dispositions censurées voilà c'est pas
arrivé et que les communes qui veulent
bénéficier de ce type de dispositif on y
note financière de la région comme quoi
c'était possible mais effectivement
c'est très compliqué c'est long à venir
mais il faut imaginer la la la détresse
du monde enseignant des enfants mais
cette détresse elle est compliquée les
compliqué pour tout le monde le coc
ville a touché tout le monde pas la
faute du gouvernement si alcoa vide mais
en revanche après ce nombre important de
vagues et ça a été dit c'est pas la
dernière on aurait pu imaginer qu'un
certain nombre de mesures aurait été
prise et surtout qu'on ait une
visibilité nos enfants ils sont capables
d'entendre beaucoup de choses si on
prend le temps de leur expliquer quand
vous changé trois fois de protocole dans
une semaine c'est pas possible et je
reviens sur la question pousser les murs
pour les classes même si c'est hyper
compliqué c'est encore demander un
effort aux enseignants on aurait pu
effectivement aller un peu plus loin le
gros problème qu'ont annoncé les
cantines et serait que la cantine c'est
le pire moment parce que c'est le moment
on enlève les masques pour manger
souvent sont des salles qui sont trop
petit et on en est à faire trois parfois
même quatre services et donc vous avez
des enfants qui mangent à 11h15 et les
derniers qui mangent à 14 heures c'est
satisfaisant pour personne ce qui est
certain c'est que il faut qu'on se
prépare la suite on nous avait expliqué
qu' on avait pris pris les toutes les
leçons à prendre du premier confinement
et que notamment sur tout ce qui était
un outil informatique on allait
faciliter les classes à distance je
parle pas des maternelles et
élémentaires là forcément mais dès le
collège des lycées on aurait pu aller
beaucoup plus loin là aussi on attend
toujours et encore le gouvernement c'est
frustrant ça mais naturellement les gens
en colère et puis ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont peur à beaucoup de gens qui
arrêtent qui craquent soit des pressions
soient dans la maladie parce qu'ils ont
peur pour leur santé ils ont ils ont
toujours pas de masques ffp2 et de fait
la ou déjà c'était compliqué on a de
plus en plus de profs absents rajoutez à
ça la violence qui existait déjà dans
beaucoup beaucoup d'établissements en
france je vous rappelle quand même qu'on
a la pire note de l'oscd la pire note en
matière de violence de condition de
faire classe et ça aussi c'est pas
tolérés effectivement on va avoir une
réaction télégramme dans ce sens ça
puisqu'on a posé à la question le grand
krach âge à qui la faute voici certaines
réactions patricia qui nous lie je suis
enseignante depuis 25 ans et je ne peux
que confirmer que l'ambiance générale
que ce soit en classe avec les parents
la hiérarchie se dégrade de jour en jour
on va aller justement posé la question
également un oui le pas de vagues jean
michel blanquer égale pas de vagues à
chaque fois qu'il y avait un problème
dans un tel établissement il y avait les
consignes de dire ce sont des bruits de
pas un dit rien et ça aussi on le paye
aujourd'hui la crise sanitaire est un
révélateur de la crise structurelle de
l'éducation nationale je pourrais vous
en donner énormément exemple sur ma
commune et on a un nez la déliquescence
de l'éducation nationale parce qu'on a
retiré beaucoup d'autorité aux
professeurs et aux directeurs d'école
justement au titre de ce pas de vagues
fait pas trop de bruit non on va pas
exclure telle élèves non on va pas et ça
c'est très très pénibles
nicolas glières essentiel de rappeler
qu'il ya d'un côté la détresse des
enfants et des treize enseignants
aujourd'hui à l'aune de la crise
sanitaire qui est dramatique mais que
comme vous l'avez dit la crise interne
est un révélateur de problèmes beaucoup
plus profond il est temps de passer à
autre chose pour la crise sanitaire et
de voir que ce soit un problème
structurel de l'école éric zemmour on a
parlé sa stratégie pour sortir la crise
sanitaire elle a répété plusieurs fois
j'allais en parlait justement vu vous
couper l'herbe sous le pied vous avez
vous saurez
vous verrez vous allez voir
vous avez la stratégie vaccinale pour
les personnes âgées pour qu'on sorte de
cette épidémie vous avez le fait
d'utiliser des traitements qui sont un
outil extrêmement efficace pour lutter
contre la pandémie est derrière au
niveau de la santé faire en sorte qu'on
remette de l'argent de l'hôpital fait en
sorte qu'on met de l'argent dans la
recherche c'est pour sortir de
l'épidémie et de l'autre vous parliez de
la blouse je pense que c'est un
excellent sujet si vous voulez qu'on en
débatte aussi pour rappeler que c'est le
professeur qui est au centre du projet
éducatif et non pas l'élève pardonnez
moi même
en espèces est ce que vous dégraisser le
mammouth pour reprendre une expression
d'un an se terminer et l'éducation 1997
socialistes d'ailleurs déjà il ya 25 ans
on voulait réduire est ce que vous êtes
dans ce sens où on rajoute t moyens on
augmente les professeurs réduit les
classes comme le proposait et on va vous
donner la parole je vois qu'à nicolas
guerre s'arrête là blues parce que si
c'était une proposition bien la
décomposition de la suppression du
collège unique est une proposition le
fin du collège unique oui c'est aussi le
collège unique silence fut jamais vous
mettez
on va dire dans l'objectif des
occasionnels le fait que ce soit non pas
l'éducation qui est un projet parental
d'éducation mais l'instruction publique
où vous remettez l'accent sur les
fondamentaux sur les français sur les
maths de re donner des cours de français
en enlevant une partie des langues
étrangères dans les programmes de
primaires tout ça sont des mesures qui
sont extrêmement concrètes pour
améliorer la vie des enseignants et
l'éducation qu'on donne aux élèves au
sein de l'éducation publique française
nicolas glières enseignants et membres
des stylos jour roja merci d'être avec
nous également quand vous entendez ces
diverses propositions ça vous inspire
quoi
aujourd'hui vous êtes un professeur en
colère ont tout simplement résigné
résignez jamais en colère clairement
monsieur blanquart a une énorme
responsabilité dans la situation de
l'école aujourd'hui il a détruit le bas
comme dans un bac locale il a détruit 10
et en en faisant un lycée à 15 vitesse
mais il faut rappeler quand même et on
le rappelle sans arracher les stylos
rouges que nadja de l'eau belkacem a
déjà détruit de la même manière les cols
en gros cela fait trente ans que tous
les gouvernements successifs ont détruit
l'école comme l'hôpital a été détruite
ont détruit les services publics dans ce
pays nous aujourd'hui on est en colère
parce que rien n'a été fait par rapport
à la situation sanitaire depuis deux ans
on demande chez les stylos rouges
régulièrement à mettre en place et de
mes groupes pendant les vagues pendant
les pires périodes comme le représentant
de mme pécresse en parlait d'ailleurs
l'idée de de faire du distanti elle un
jour sur deux par exemple tout le monde
fait un effort et les parents et les
profs et les élèves les élèves
voilà on regarde et on
travaille mais comment fait on quand on
travaille mais nous travaillons aussi et
on a de nombreux collègues qui sont
parents aussi comment font-ils il
s'arrange ils font comme ils peuvent
déjà les gens télétravail peuvent garder
un jour sur de leurs enfants la maison
ceux qui ne peuvent pas c'est autre
chose on trouve des solutions pareil
nous ça fait un an et demi qu'on avait
proposé que des communes utilisent les
salles par exemple vide nous
n'utiliserons pleine période de pandémie
pour que les élèves soient repliés
surveillé par du personnel par exemple
de mairie pendant pour l'heure fait pour
à distance
rien n'a été pris en compte monsieur
blogueur n'a jamais rien écouté et
j'aimerais aussi rajouter que monsieur
blanc caire a bon dos c'est bien entendu
de son fait sa marotte son obsession de
ne jamais nous écoutent et de ne pas
nous augmenter de nous mépriser mais
c'est de monsieur macron qui décide en
dernier lieu et c'est bien monsieur
mccaw qui a décidé de suivre son
ministre lui-même coachée par même mâcon
qui n'a aucune légitimité
constitutionnelle
donc nous nous aimerions vraiment que
monsieur blanc caire soient renvoyés on
parle pas de démission veut qu'il soit
revoyez et on n'aimerait pas qu'un clown
soient mis à la place mais que quelqu'un
coût de soigner à la place quelqu'un qui
avec lyon pour engager des discussions
au niveau de nos rémunérations sont
scandaleuses on doit nous augmenter d'au
moins 40% pour rattraper s'étaient
perdus depuis 83 c'est un calcul que
tous les partis politiques toutes les
personnes avec qui on a plus parlé y
compris les gens du ministère de
l'éducation nationale monsieur pereiro
et autres ces chiffres il était d'accord
avec donc il ya un moment il faut nous
respecter nous nous payer nous protéger
du virus protéger les enfants et il faut
que tout le monde fasse un effort dans
cette pandémie
les deux me groupe était une solution
était possible
il y a des solutions possibles on nous a
jamais entendu il n'y a aucun
pragmatisme du côté de la rue de
grenelle on a affaire à des amateurs et
des et des menteurs concrètement alors
on va avancer schiffrin d'éducation
nationale en 2021 effectivement pas
brillant 1400 enseignants qui ont
démissionné au cours de l'année un
chiffre qui aurait triplé en dix ans
payer voire % moins que leurs collègues
européens
90% en fin dé des enseignants qui évoque
une charge de travail qui augmente tous
les ans et enfin 31% qui envisagerait de
changer de métier vincent jean brun si
valérie pécresse arrive aux affaires
qu'est ce qu'elle va changer
concrètement
pour faire évoluer les choses dans le
bon sens parce que c'est vrai qu'on a vu
nos deux amis l'ont dit enseignants et
gouvernements successifs n'ont rien fait
pour améliorer la situation
on pourrait évidemment on débattra faire
le bilan de chacun kenna mais la vérité
c'est que la première chose qui a été
dit là et qu'il faut vraiment entendre
c'est on veut être écouté
quel que soit le président la présidente
de la république demain elle n'aura pas
de baguette magique mais le respect dû à
un véritable dialogue avec les
enseignants qui sont les hussards noirs
de la république sans eux on ne forme
plus de citoyens dans notre pays donc on
a éminemment besoin d'eux on ne peut pas
accepter et c'est vrai le parallèle avec
l'hôpital est très juste on doit avoir
pour protéger les français pour éduquer
les français on doit avoir des gens qui
soient motivés qu'ils soient heureux et
épanoui et ça passe par un meilleur
cadre de travail et certainement par des
rémunérations qui soit juste je prends
ma part aujourd'hui
je ne prendrai
le concret il est bien plus concrète le
vôtre excusez moi mais je vous ai cité
des propositions l'occurrence que vous
avez cités la blouse on est dans
l'adversité je sonde vers les gérer deux
processeurs qui sont là on va leur
demander ce qu'ils sont impatients du
retour de la pelouse d'arles soyons
sérieux deux minutes il ya vraiment une
question fondamentale sur les écoutes
valérie pécresse elle a pu
l'expérimenter à l'échelle des lycées
franciliens et je peux vous assurer que
le dialogue a été de qualité et on
redresse la barre même s'il ya encore
beaucoup à faire sur des sujets aussi
importants demain il faut écouter et
crée les perspectives le sujet il est là
on peut pas être dans une tour d'ivoire
comme c'est le cas de monsieur macron de
monsieur blanc caire on doit construire
avec les personnels de l'éducation moi
j'ai des amis qui sont professeurs
autour de moi et le 10 le salaire est
évidemment un point majeur c'est un
point majeur mais c'est pas le seul on
veut être respecté on veut sortir du pas
de vagues on veut des outils travail de
qualité on veut faire en sorte de
pouvoir faire vraiment le métier qu'on a
choisi à savoir transmettre et instruire
et pas faire la police en cours il ya
des établissements aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus faire cours sereinement dans
la classe parce que le calme minimum ne
s'y prêtent pas et c'était vrai avant la
crise sanitaire et malheureusement ce
sera vrai après si on en sortait donc
c'est tout ça qu'il faut mettre en
oeuvre et cette capacité de dialogue et
de rassemblement je sais pour bien
connaître valérie pécresse que c'est au
coeur de sa façon de faire le programme
est sur l'éducation sera dévoilé au
cours de cette campagne à quelques
mesures déjà qu'ils sont sortis
notamment le fait qu'on puisse passer un
examen niveau à la fin de l'élémentaire
cas pour que les enfants ne soient pas
envoyés dans le collège unique comme ça
sans savoir lire écrire compter un jeu
les chiffres sont dramatiques on a moins
en moins d'enfants qui savent lire
écrire compter à la sortie du primaire
et donc pouvoir aller vers une
sixième de consolidation qui permettrait
d'avoir un véritable sas pour rattraper
le retard de la même manière qu'il faut
effectivement plus d'heures de sur les
fondamentaux le français les
mathématiques sur les salaires parce que
j'invite la région mm montrer ces
chiffres à regarder la france et tout le
monde derrière
sur les chiffres de 2 l' ocde un
bond dernière sur les sur les salaires
que fait valérie pécresse en ce sens on
sait que anne hidalgo voudrait doubler
les salaires on va vous poser la
question l'excentrique
supprimé 250 mille postes de
fonctionnaires donc pour l'éducation
nationale c'est quand même pas
incroyable alors revoyez vos fiches
puisque voilà pécresse a été très clair
sur le fait que pour se dégager des
marges de manoeuvre il y aura un non
renouvellement d'un fonctionnaire sur
trois jusqu'à atteindre un chiffre de
200 milles et non pas deux cent
cinquante mille comme vous l'évoquez
pour refinancer et la création de 50
mille postes de fonctionnaires dans des
secteurs on en a absolument besoin la
justice évidemment l'éducation est
évidemment la sécurité la protection et
c'est bien dommage aux affaires
et à ministre nicolas sarkozy parce
qu'elle aurait pu faire tant de choses
incroyables les bas-fonds s'est déjà
renseigné vous puisque quand elle était
mise lancer leur saison puisqu'elle en a
fait énormément de choses et l'inversé
la diversité elle n'a rien fait parce
que je savais très bien c'est banal
aujourd'hui c'est de l'amusement est
peut-être passé cette mesure est et les
mesures que vous avez cités c'est celle
que j'étais je veux dire mais chez moi
je me suis pas permis nous interrompt
mais surtout on sait des personnes et
des personnels la d'éducation nationale
qui sont face à nous et je crois qu'on
leur doit beaucoup plus que des
chicaneries sur un plateau télé on doit
se poser les bonnes questions moi je
n'imagine pas être élu dans un pays où
les professeurs démissionne ou les
médecins démissionne ou toutes les
personnes qui sont au coeur des services
publics qui font la fierté d'un grand
pays comme la france en viennent à
détester leur travail qu'il faut bien
qu'ils ont choisies ont passé des
concours pour le faire donc le but n'est
pas dire on va traiter absolument tous
les professeurs de la même manière et
augmenté de 30 % tel ou tel c'est pas le
sujet le sujet c'est comment sur le
terrain on fait en sorte que les
professeurs demain s'épanouissent
comment ont recréé en valorisent cette
fonction d'enseignant en redonnant un
cadre travaillant une légitimité travail
et évidemment les moyens de travailler
et ce ne sera pas une fonction attractif
demain sicile et les professeurs ou les
candidats à la fonction professeurs se
disent c'est pas assez payés donc il ya
évidemment à remettre tout ça sur sur la
table mais je pense qu'il faut agir de
manière pragmatique dans un dialogue
avec les représentations rae retrouver
un professeur fabrice ratibi mais avant
justement sur cet état des professeurs
est amoral regarder ce sondage édifiant
76 100 estime avoir des troubles du
sommeil 27% qui s'ils aiment leur métier
épuisant 51% qui déclarent avoir déjà eu
recours à un arrêt de travail fabrice
frattini là je vais me faire
volontairement provocatrice parce que ce
sont des questions qui peuvent voilà ici
ou là se pose est quand qu on ne connaît
pas votre métier on se dit bah voilà les
professeurs ont beaucoup plus de
vacances que des cadres du privé ou tout
simplement des salariés du privé
comment vous expliquer ces chiffres
terribles sur sur l'état des troupes
c'est j'ose dire sur l'état du moral des
troupes
une chose déjà ce recul travail il ya
toujours ton travail devant élèves et
d'autres tout travail c'est comme pour
vous en tant que journaliste vous faites
une émission d'une heure ne travaille
pas eu une heure par journée nous
faisons une nous sommes des 4 as de la
fonction publique nous avoir un bac + 5
nous avons un travail qui est
intellectuelle donc oui nous avons
besoin du temps en 12 heures en dehors
des salles de classe et c'est un temps
qui est très précieux 1 par rapport ce
combat enseigner ensuite auprès d'un
auprès de nos élèves et justement il ya
une charge de travail qui augmente les
charges de travail qui de plus en plus
complexes de plus avec de plus en plus
de tâches et bien sûr il y a aussi
informé
des raisons administratives des raisons
aussi politique des changements de
programme sans 1
507 les programmes changent également
des niveaux de haut niveau des de ces
programmes qui sont de réformes qui
compte de plus en plus à l'opposé du
sens que nous faisons du métier il ya
qu'à voir la réforme parcours sup la
réforme du bac juste pour vous dire par
exemple l'élève de terminale ont leur
bac dans six semaines alors que se
vanter de bander ni comment je veux
j'enseigne d'éternel comment est ce que
moi je peux me regarder dans un miroir
et me dire je vais réussir à les prépare
au bac il y a eu deux libres et des
dernières confient donc ans lorsqu'il
était en seconde il ya une anxiété qui
est terrible par rapport à ça les élèves
sont anxieux comment est ce que moi je
peux me dire je fais bien mon métier je
fais du bachotage pendant six mois et
derrière je fait corps derrière ma
matière janssen quoi et ça ce n'est
qu'un exemple qu'un exemple avec les
terminales pareil avec cette réforme du
bac ou dès la classe de seconde
déjà que les élèves choisis des
spécialités qui vont des enfermés qu'ils
vont devoir fermer des portes avec la
violence de parcours sud derrière donc
bien sûr notre métier de perdre son sens
maintenant à nouveau que les terminales
sont en même temps certificateur et
pédagogue on doit mettre des notes qui
comptent qui compte pour le bac donc
bien sûr nous perdons tous nos repères
en tant que pédagogue et et c'est une
charge mentale qui était quoi qui est
compliqué oui il ya des collègues je
suis représentant syndical oui j'ai des
collègues qui dort très mal nous avons
tous le moins - y compris notre depuis
ça te crées zuco vite depuis toutes ces
réformes nous avons des problèmes de
sommeil c'est évident ils connaissent
très bien nicolas glières vous vous
partagez ce diagnostic que de fabrice
traquini parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est parti sur cette
mobilisation contre ces protocoles voilà
la base des protocoles mais là on va au
delà la situation s'est vraiment empiré
dans dont le fond même dans le fondement
de votre métier vous êtes d'accord
complètement on a une charge de travail
qui a fait qui a passé son temps à
augmenter depuis les années 80 sans
salaire je dérape et tout à l'heure sont
la moindre contrepartie on fait plus
d'heures de cours qu'avant dans le sens
où on a plus de copie parce que plus
d'élèves les classes sont que chargé on
nous a rajouté des tâches on a des
réunions gratuites non rémunéré je
connais pas un boulot ça ait lieu des
réunions selon l'humeur selon l'envi le
délire du chef d'établissement qui peut
décider de nous réunir sous menace de ne
pas louper notre journée de travail
parce qu'on n'est pas venu à une réunion
une heure la énième dans une période
donnée les conseils de classe dur de
plus en plus longtemps des réunions
parents profs sont de plus en plus
courante régulière est longue sans un
centime toutes ces choses là ne sont pas
rémunérés donc on est épuisé on se sent
déconsidérer y compris par la population
je l'aï ya aussi une politique si vous
voulez qu'ils doivent un petit peu
réfléchir par rapport à notre métier il
ya aussi la population générale les
parents compris fermé mais pourquoi nous
mépris style pourquoi sont ils dans
cette attitude consumériste par rapport
à l'école nous sommes là pour
transmettre des connaissances à leurs
enfants nous ne sommes pas des ennemis
ou ne doit pas réglé ses comptes par
rapport à l'école qu'on a connu avec
nous les parents doivent être
respectueux le gouvernement doit être
respectueux quels qu'ils soient quelle
que soit sa couleur politique et nous
n'avons pas su ressenti là
sur le terrain nous avons des reproches
des critiques on a 100 % des parents qui
sont devenus proches on sait pas par
quel miracle qui savent comment faire
court qui savent nous expliquer comment
faire court on a un gouvernement qui
nous change de programme sans arrêt
comme mon collègue l'a très bien dit
nous ça fait très longtemps chez les
ch'ti au rouge qu'on demande une enquête
pour conflit d'intérêt au niveau de
l'éducation nationale savoir qui parmi
les membres de l'éducation nationale
dont les hauts fonctionnaires ont des
copains de la famille de marie ou des
femmes dans les maisons d'édition on
veut le savoir on veut une enquête
indépendante la france est-elle une
république bananière oui ou non si c'est
le cas on l'espère sinon on fait quelque
chose merci en tout cas à tous les deux
ans fabrice frattini nicolas de lire
pour votre témoignage merci à vous deux
maxence briques et vincent genvrin sur
ce plateau et d'avoir accepté donc ce
débat merci